the question is are birds real now I
would say yes but others seem to not
agree they believe the government
replaced birds with deep State agents
who surveilled the American citizenry is
it crazy sure it is it's also the
subject of a new Fox Nation special
birds are fake the conspiracy take a
look
the birds are dirty smelly extermination
of our pigeon population
[Music]
here in a dungeon dungeon and birds are
robots
it is a bird brain Theory just because
it's a theory doesn't mean that it is a
bunch of nonsense it's 56 years I've
been doing these pigeons I think I know
what I'm talking about this is a
coordinated effort to systematically
remove all of the birds why should we
concerned about that
[Music]
birds are fake the conspiracy is out now
on Fox Nation and Peter McAdoo is the
public information officer of birds
aren't real
so Peter you're telling me you believe
that there are no living birds I believe
it I know it you know it I know it as
proof yes all birds uh every bird in the
U.S I know that include chickens there's
a chicken a bird a chicken's a bird a
chicken's a bird so I just fed my
chickens
back home they didn't seem to be robots
yeah that's kind of how biotechnology
works the government's making uh bio
hybrids where there are birds and robots
uh that the government's combining Annie
Jacobson's done some great work on it so
you're saying they have human
characteristics the eyes the wings not
human characteristics have bird
characteristics what the government did
is from 1959 through 2001 they
systematically replaced every uh bird in
the sky with a government surveillance
drone replica that looks identical to a
real bird spies on us every day so when
you walk outside I mean it's probably
you know 100 cameras in here there's
more cameras outside than there are so
hold on we can't win Foreign Wars and we
can't run a DMV but we can control every
bird in the sky we can I mean and I
appreciate you allowing me to share this
information on here a lot of the media
won't let me talk about is this a
schnick
I mean do you really I mean do you
really in your heart why would it be a
stick
because I mean you you report everywhere
you report on UFOs in the show yes well
I don't report on them UFOs are I mean I
respect what you guys talk about on here
you're letting bird robots on the show
you're letting UFOs so do you think I
could see the government using some
birds maybe as drones to disguise them
but you're saying all birds the pigeons
here in New York City every every bird
every bird in every pigeon here in New
York City and uh I mean it's it's really
an epidemic it's a bird this is a real
Theory there are real people out there
yes the road theory has been going on
since the 80s it's on the media you can
find it it's just like uh really
everything else out there truth is
subjective there's different proof for
different things and if you do your own
research look into it you might find
that out there you go go to Fox Nation
birds are fake is we're looking into
this Theory or conspiracy theory hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else